[Music]
hello there you are watching The Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive over the next
half an hour we'll see what is making
the headlines with the journalist and
broadcaster Jenny cleeman and the author
and sports journalist mihir Bose very
good evening to you both and uh no
prizes for guessing what's on most of
the front pages let's take you through
some of them the mirror keeps it simple
paying tribute to the late Brazilian
footballer Legend Pele as the best
the star describes Pele as the real goat
greatest of all time of course in other
news the telegraph understands that the
government is considering reintroducing
some covert travel restrictions after
other countries placed restrictions on
Chinese passengers arriving to the UK
the express quotes the defense secretary
Ben Wallace is insistent that there is
no magic money warned that would allow
for above inflation pay Rises that might
bring some of the strikes to an end the
eye hears that more than 1800 police
recruits had as part of former prime
minister Boris Johnson's efforts to
bring more people into the police have
now resigned and the guardian carries
figures showing that one in 10
conservative peers has been given in
excess of has has given in excess of a
hundred thousand pounds to the party and
the financial times quotes increasing
inflation and interest rates is the main
reason for a fallen the number of
mergers and Acquisitions in the second
half of this year and just to remind you
that by scanning the QR code on this
screen join the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's papers
while you watch us discuss them all and
just to remind you we've got Jenny
kleeman and me here Bose here with me
this evening very good to talk to you
both well let's talk about Pele some
striking pictures some striking memories
on all the front pages more or less and
let's start Jenny with this I mean it's
one of the most iconic pictures of Pele
of all time there are so many The Daily
Star Pele the greatest footballer of all
time dies at 82 the real Goat as we've
explained that means greatest of all
time embracing Bobby Moore there after
their Titanic battle in the World Cup in
1970.
yes and this kind of captures this this
spirit that Pele had that he felt
football uh could bring peace to the
world
um a very famous famous uh image from
the 1970s World Cup uh and I what I find
interesting is is this idea of the goat
uh which it wasn't really part of our
last lexicon was it until
um a few years ago with the gymnast
Simone biles but there's been so much of
a a question uh over the world cup of
who's the greatest footballer of all
time and I think most people would say
Pele was up there he was certainly uh
the first Global footballing Superstar
and seeing all the tributes pouring out
today about how much he mattered to
football how much he mattered to Brazil
how much he mattered to poorer people in
Brazil he made football entertaining he
turned it into a kind of global
spectacle and even though we don't have
as much footage of him playing football
as we do of the other contesters Messi
and Ronaldo or other others who might uh
want to be contenders for the title of
goat uh Maradona who has also passed
away people from from different eras
um he is an inspiration to all of them
as we've seen these outpouring of
tributes on uh social media today
um so he you know he was an ambassador
for football for Brazil and and for so
much more I mean here it really is a
great photograph that isn't it those
were us that were around to remember it
from that that game England lost one nil
didn't they it isn't Pele saying to
Bobby Moore there as they've exchanged
shirts you can see Bobby Moore holding
the the Brazilian shirt isn't he saying
to him see you in the final
absolutely and I remember that match
Dermot it shows my age I I was a student
uh sitting in a in a very cold bed set
in in Clapham watching the match live
and it was a great match it also had one
of the greatest saves from pele's Header
by Gordon bank which is probably
considered the greatest
um goalkeeping
um feat by anybody uh and and that those
were the words exchanged and England
were expected England had a better team
than in 1966 in the opinion of many
people uh but England didn't get there
they they they lost uh on the Sunday uh
following to Germany and of course the
um the Thursday when the elections came
the country took its revenge and through
Harold Wilson out of power but that's a
different story
um the point is that what Pele did apart
from playing magical football which the
Brazilians did creating things on the
field of play which made you believe in
myth and magic and you know made
everybody think you know what a
wonderful game it is he connected Brazil
up in a way you know Brazil has had a
very tortured past the last country to
abolish slavery but here was Pele a
black man putting a team together of
different colors and different races and
I remember in in 1977 when Pele had
retired he was playing for New York
Cosmos I was working for the Sunday
Times and I was in Kolkata in in India
and he arrived and a hundred thousand
people turned up at the airport at 10 30
at night to welcome him and the local
government said that in his honor we
will repair the roads of the city and if
you've ever been to Kolkata repairing
the roads of that city is a huge task
not that they did much but nevertheless
it shows that this bond that he could
create which went beyond football and of
course you know Jenny is right we don't
have much footage of Pele people will
argue about
um Messi and Maradona one must say Pele
didn't have the Dark Side of Maradona
you know that that is also a factor and
and of course you may say
um it's because of my you know having
watched football for so long and so on
it may be an age reflection thing that
we think of penne as the greatest but I
think he should be honored and the way
the papers of today had had him on the
front pages just shows what an impact
he's had even the financial times yeah I
was just about to mentioned that me here
farewell Pele the financial time says
football great dies at 82 and points at
us so many of the the papers do looking
at the express there back into color on
the front of the express their Pele
after that historic third victory in the
world cup that magical Brazil team got
to therefore hold on to the jewelry made
trophy there because they'd they'd made
it a hat-trick never done again no
perhaps likely to be Jenny
absolutely and you know he was he's he
broke so many records set so many made
so many firsts he was the you know the
youngest person to score a goal in a
World Cup final extraordinary really and
uh you know this is a time when as we
said before that we didn't we didn't
necessarily have the footage we do have
those those photographs we do have those
images uh and the impact of these images
is still massive today we know that um
for example even though in Brazil
everybody knew this was coming he was
having palliative care he'd had
treatment for colon cancer
um you know this is a shock for people
in Brazil I was looking on on Twitter
sort of outpourings of of grief in
Brazil and three days of of mourning
announced he was a real hero for the
country and as me here says this is uh a
black man in in a country that until
fairly recently 50 odd years uh
beforehand there had been slavery in
there but also a pork a poor man in a
country of great inequality uh as well
who's risen to become you know perhaps
the country's most iconic hero
and me here you mentioned that you know
some controversy surrounding Pele of
course well unlike I suppose another
contemporary of his different sport of
course but around about the same era
Muhammad Ali he didn't really take on
the the politics of the time head on
no it obviously a different situation in
in Brazil but he Muhammad Ali decided
that you know he had to
um stand up for the for the rights of
the black people in in America and so on
and on a wider scale Muhammad Ali went
on a very different track
um felt his football did the talking and
that he should let his football
um Express what he wanted to express and
and he took that view and and I you know
I think um that was a very reasonable
um and a very sagacious view for him to
take because I think
um by doing that he also connected up so
many people with the game because young
people taking to football would would
see him as their icon as you said the
go-to though that word has come in only
lately to use as to you know that they
could use football to express themselves
I mean that is important sport gives
this opportunity for people to do things
on on the field of play to believe that
just by playing football they can do
things with other other
um other than Avenues in life do not
provide and and that is very important
the symbol um of what Pele becomes and
the hope he holds out whether the hope
is fulfilled or not of the different
matter but the hope he holds out is
immense Jenny I just want to pick up
with you on Plenty other stories of
course on the front of the papers this
is back to the express it's in other
papers as well uh no magic wand for pay
rise is this from the defense secretary
Ben Wallace speaking today he's gone for
magic wand rather than Magic Money Tree
yes well you know they have to pick
their metaphors don't they but it all it
all means the same thing I mean Ben
Wallace is uh is perhaps one of the most
likable members of the cabinet and when
he he speaks I think people listen uh a
bit more than than they do uh perhaps
other senior members of government but
we had the new uh head of the TUC on the
airwaves this morning uh basically
saying that the government need to not
hide behind hide behind pay review
boards something has to give
um and you've got to remember that the
the you know the government is being led
by
um a prime minister who in the
leadership campaign both he and Liz
trust were kind of really competing to
be The Heirs to Margaret Thatcher and
and sticking it to the unions was really
part of that so there is a sense that
the government isn't going to budge but
also a sense that these strikes are not
going away we know that we have nurses
and and uh ambulance staff sets us to
strike again in January in this kind of
intransigence on both sides it means
that it's it's all of us that are are
going to be feeling the effects of all
of it something has to give okay uh stay
with us we're going to take a break now
now coming up uh we're going to also be
paying tribute to another site death
announced today another icon the fashion
designer Dame Vivian Westwood whose
death was announced today join us in a
few minutes
[Music]
thank you
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview I've got Jenny cleeman and Mejia
Bose discussing all the stories as they
come in and uh so many of them sad we've
just been discussing haven't we uh the
death the passing of the football legend
Pele and uh another Legend entirely
different feel though uh also die today
certainly a death was announced today a
Dame Vivian Westwood uh let's have a
look at how the Mirror covers it and uh
this is Punk's style fashion designer
Westwood dies at the age of 81. now um I
don't know about YouTube but I certainly
interviewed her at least a couple of
times
um did uh you know Vivian Westwood at
all
yes I did meet her and um I um and I was
very impressed by her um her her
ferocious uh belief that we must do
something about
um um climate change and you know
um that the that we must change the way
um we behave and so on and I remember
having a long discussion with her where
I said yes of course we should do
something about climate change there's
no question about it but uh Vivian you
must also take into account the fact
that the poorer countries feel that the
Richer countries have have exploited the
um the world and therefore how will they
lift themselves up you know we need to
actually change the way we look at
economic Prosperity we've only got one
model of economic Prosperity which is
the one that has been set by the the
Richer countries of having cars and big
houses and and and things like that and
and she took that on board and as a
result of that she asked me to write
something for her website on it but I
was in impressed with her passion on
this and and the way she felt about it
and the way she had looked at the
problems you know and and and I must say
before I had met her I wasn't aware of
how strongly she felt on it I'd just
seen her as a fashion designer but she
had obviously considered these very
important issues as well and that's the
point isn't it Jenny um even just as the
fashion designer she had to make a
statement to put a spoke in things as
she said but that statement was
sometimes explicit it was it was written
on the clothing
yes it was I mean she was she was a punk
fashion designer and that also meant
sometimes uh being outrageous in her
statements as a punk who is a fashion
designer but also Punk fashion
um but she also made really great
clothes she made strong clothes that
women love to wear they were strong and
flattering clothes you could uh look
smart and stylish but also a little bit
edgy in them uh very distinctive kind of
look at it you know she was her clothes
were were sold in very high-end places
she was a high-end fashion designer we
having begun with a shop on uh you know
in in with Malcolm McLaren designing
punk clothes uh in the in in the late
70s she's come a long way but you know
she was successful as an activist and as
a as a fashion designer because people
liked her and she was edgy
um but she was sort of just edgy enough
she was just edgy enough that we would
listen to her and her clothes were
fantastically wearable just want to take
a look I think we've got time for it one
other
story this on the front of the telegraph
ministers to look at new covid travel
Kurds Rishi sonak the paper says is
considering the return of covert travel
restrictions for the first time since
pandemic rules were scrapped in the
spring because of concerns about Rising
cases in China it's almost exactly three
years on me here is it happening again
well it could happen and and what would
be interesting is if it comes in where
will they do the testing will they do
the testing for passengers before they
board the flights to UK or will they do
the testing when they arrive and there's
a very good case to be said for the
testings to be done particularly from
passengers from China and that's what
we're talking about now when they come
back to when they arrive in this country
a because frankly let's face it given
what the way China has behaved we can't
be sure of how well the Chinese test
would be and secondly if we do the tests
here we might find some more information
about the um about the virus because I
don't think enough information is coming
from China if not misleading information
is coming from China about what is going
on there Jenny do you think it will
happen though because uh the paper also
says we know it um we know that Mr sunac
who has been critical of lockdown since
leaving the treasury and has argued that
not enough consideration was taken of
the effect on children and the economy
and this time last year or a bit earlier
he flew back from the United States to
avoid lockdown over Omicron
oh this is different lockdown isn't the
same as as travel restrictions but
nonetheless I mean the paper says uh
introducing restrictions or tests on
people returning from China hasn't been
ruled out that doesn't mean it's going
to happen I have to say I hope it
doesn't happen uh there is of course a
real question mark over data from China
and you know America is is asking
passengers from China to test before
they leave the country Italy is asking
passengers from China to test when they
arrive so that they can get a sense on
the genomic sequencing it is true that
we cannot trust what China says but so
far the evidence suggests that there
aren't new variants in China even though
there are great numbers we have to have
faith in our vaccines they either work
or they don't work and if they work we
have to hope that they'll they'll work
against passengers coming in from any
country there is a huge problem with
getting accurate data from China and I
think stories like this are a way of
pushing the envelope and perhaps hoping
that China will be a bit more
transparent and open I think China said
that there were five thousand UK cases
of covert today whereas it's expected
that I think the the external estimates
are 250 million people uh had covered in
December so those figures the official
figures can't be right but I don't
necessarily think we should lose face
faith in our uh vaccines simply because
there's an explosion of cases in China